Eddie is actually my older brother and
Eric's a good friend of Eddie's but we
started back in 2010 so the Jubilee
project was not something we kind of
said oh we're going to start the Jubilee
project rather as a response to the
haiti earthquake and it was more of you
know we wanted to do something about it
so we decided you know we didn't have
that much money but we decided to go out
until in New York subway stop and busque
to raise a hundred dollars for Haiti and
that day be raised about seventy dollars
at the subway stop but we've been a
video about it we put out mine and about
a week we had raised over seven hundred
dollars I'm had over a thousand views in
that video so I was the first time we
said wow you know videos in social media
are such a powerful medium to do a lot
of good and I assumed that after Eddie
and Eric join me and we started what we
call the Jubilee project now they just
give you some context of how we came on
board Jason started this in 2010 Eric
happened to be at Harvard med school and
I was actually working at the White
House for last couple of years and we
got to a point in our career where we
felt like something was just missing you
know we hit our dream jobs we were
working in really high functioning
society and yet we felt like you know we
weren't really utilizing our passions
and there was something bigger out there
that was bigger than ourselves and so we
felt was tugging at our hearts where we
thought you know the social media thing
is has so much potential and that we can
really make an impact in the lives of
young people and so the collectively we
decided and we talked to my parents and
they said they gave us sort of their
blessings and we decided to quit our
jobs eric is taking a leave of absence
from school and Jason quit his job at
Bain and I have my job and we decided to
pack up our car move to irvine and now
we're hearing so we've been here for the
last two months now and it's been an
amazing journey
I think for me one of the most impactful
video that we've made is called picture
perfect and it was used to support this
organization called be the match and the
story the idea of this film was inspired
by this individual named Janet laying
and she was diagnosed with leukemia
about a year ago and unfortunately
passed away just a couple weeks ago but
not without having left a legacy behind
where she created this incredibly
powerful social media campaign and
movement to get especially the
asian-american community rallied behind
to register to become bone marrow donors
and potentially saving hundreds of
thousands of other lives in the future
and so this was a story that touched us
deeply and we wanted to respond to it
with this video so we partner up with
her foundation and worked with her to
make sure that we not only make this
issue aware but that we also are able to
get people even more people to register
as well yeah
yeah a lot of people ask us how how do
we choose our stories how to do that
causes especially I'm since if you take
a look at our videos we tend to just
have a variance of different different
issues that we care about and it all
again happens very organically you know
there's some issues that we are very
that are near and dear to our souls
personally sex trafficking you know
anti-bullying education and then there's
some organizations out there who have
watched our videos and said you know we
want to partner with you and they care
about different issues and then they
come to us and say we'd like to work
with you on a video and so we'll take
the time to learn and talk to them and
see what their ideas are often times
they have phenomenal ones and so we'll
work together to come up with the
concepts and produce a video with them
so we've had the privilege of in the
past when creating about 70-75 videos on
numerous issues and our goal is to
continue to raise awareness for as many
issues as possible
when I was in college I think they're a
handful of older guys who are just like
really really good to me who you nobody
took me under their wing and we're true
metrics for me and you know two of the
names in the film RND and Richard and
those are two of the guys who mentioned
me and that's why you know I named them
insured I thought you guys that oh yeah
yeah but um yeah you know I mean there's
in addition to those two guys there's a
handful of guys but um yeah we I think
we've been really really blessed and
that we've had tremendous number of
incredible people just really you know
help us and mentor on us and even as
we're doing this YouTube thing in the
YouTube community we've got a lot of
people kind of reach out and say you
know we want to support view that means
the world to us there are so many people
in our lives who have made being here in
this moment possible for us and I think
it would almost do an injustice to start
naming all them just because there's so
many that we wouldn't miss but I think
the one that comes to mind for me is our
mom so Jason and I are brothers and our
mom is someone who has from a very young
age instilled in us this idea of work
ethic and just having conviction and
really sort of being a person of
character and values she came to United
States about 26 27 years ago with no you
know sort of sense of how to speak
English or this culture in coming to a
very new environment immigrated here
with very little connections here and
somehow she managed to have two kids she
was able to have many part-time jobs
while getting her bachelor's her
master's and then her PhD and somehow
navigating this very difficult world of
a lot of complexity complexities and
being able to be a teacher for this next
generation and instill in this next
generation of sense of hope and
knowledge so she just seeing her example
and seeing how hard she's worked has
given us this inspiration to go out and
work hard too and to know that no matter
who you are what difficulty
I have you can make an impact in the
lives of others love languages been one
of our biggest videos today and it was
such a surprise to us but we actually
had a tremendous response so far yeah
and we're excited to see and keep coming
in we're really excited just because we
really believe that even with something
as soon as simple as like a post-it note
you can really encourage someone or
really you know change someone's day or
change someone's life you been and you
know what we love inspiring young people
what we want to do is we want inspire
them to action is without action it
really it really doesn't matter since we
just launched a series called doing good
as contagious or DGSE where we're
actually gonna be encouraging people to
act and we're gonna be going out and
acting ourselves I'm getting involved
yeah I mean just to put assembly our
lives was we're changed by a simple
sticking out right this short film
pretty much gave us the Capitol or the
impetus to go out and do this Jubilee
positing full time and so we believe
that is something as simple as the
kingdom can change someone else's life
if you look as we talk to young people
around the country and do our college
tour and visit schools we've noticed
that there's a deep sense of hunger deep
sense of passion in kids who want to
feel like they're part of something
bigger than themselves they want their
lives matter for something and so what
we've started to realize is that you
know our role isn't just to make films
it's not just to tell stories is
actually to use these stories to empower
them and equip them and they give them
the resources ND just the push to
actually go out there and do something
so that's what a lovely image challenge
came from and you know the best part of
what we're doing like by far is the
ability to go and meet these people who
say to us that you have been an
inspiration and the reality is there
more of an inspiration to us because
they're the ones that are actually on
the ground
daily basis they're not being recognized
for what they're doing they're doing so
much good and yet you know we're the
ones that are getting the credit for
we're on the videos we're the ones that
are praised all the time but it's not us
it's not about who we are DubLi project
with so much Mormons through you guys
it's about a movement of young people
around this country and around the world
for that matter who have collectively
collectively decided that their lives
wouldn't matter for something bigger
what was really cool when we were
putting the challenge together was we
had a chance to watch all the remakes of
knowledge there are at least a hundred
of them on YouTube and what really stood
out to us was how diverse all the videos
were how a lot of them came from
different people of color different
languages as well and it was really
amazing to see how this one video was
able to inspire countless of other
remakes that ultimately brought people
together brought people from different
backgrounds geographies experiences
together and that this language of love
is a commonality for people all around
the world alright sounds like a simple
message right that regardless of who you
are what you look like or what you've
been through that you're still beautiful
and I'm really proud of that
one of our major projects this next year
is a film on the end of AIDS and so
talking about social media this is
really where we're trying to tap into
the potential social media creating
social change and as we've sort of
touched upon it already social media
really makes it possible for ordinary
people to do extraordinary things for
people to have a voice whether you want
to become a teacher whether your student
a doctor lawyer filmmaker musician
anyone can have a voice on social media
this is what we're really trying to tap
into at the end of eights film right now
we have the scientific instruments the
medicine the treatment to end aids we
know that if we give people the
medication they can prevent transmission
of HIV to other people as well there by
stopping the epidemic and so if we're
able to get treatment to people we can
stop hiv/aids which has been around for
30 years it's taken over 30 million
lives 1.8 million people die from AIDS
every single year and millions more
getting affected as well but if we can
simply get the treatment to people who
need it the most then we can stop but
the challenge right now is that there's
not enough political will to get this
going that people are feeling a little
bit too complacent too comfortable and
so with this film we want to create a
greater sense of urgency we want to tell
people that hey you know this is still a
problem and this is a problem that we
can solve there's not a lot of times in
history when you can say we can end an
epidemic that's take that's killed
millions of people and so we want to
create a film that can really just spark
the end of an epidemic
and brain treatment create energy and
excitement especially among young people
to end this disease and I think it's
hard to it's hard because it's hard to
say that we're going to create a film
that will actually end aids but really
we are excited because as we've seen
there's the powerful for me too so bass
it's so powerful but we're really
excited because we wanted to speed a
voice in that and that push will make
sure young people are aware of that and
you know if we're able to accomplish
this this would be the greatest
accomplishment of our generation to end
aids that's an incredible thing to be
part of so we're excited to play our
part
anywhere you